I'm Winston Duke and this is your
weekend - you don't want to get crazy we
can get crazy new in theaters this
weekend us and what are we gonna see us
this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
how can I help you Jordan peels latest
psychological horror thriller comes out
this weekend the Wilson family decides
to head to a beach house for a fun and
relaxing getaway with some family
friends unfortunately for them this
getaway turns into a getaway when the
family's creepy doppelgangers show up to
people the main character in this film
experiences of trauma as a child and
this is a story about that coming back
to haunt her and the trauma in this case
has its own family what we buried deep
and try not to face affects the world
that we make around us this one is for
you if you're a fan of Jordan peels
breakout directorial debut get out
creepy psychological thriller Horrors
are your thing or you've always wanted
to see yourself represented in movies
because for the Wilson family they
literally see themselves represented in
the same movie that is your weekend
ticket what will you see and check back
next week for a movie Dumbo oh I'm sorry
and check back next week for the movie
Dumbo
[Music]